[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
okay
[Musik]
ja herzlich willkommen auch von mir ja
boah
ich habe keine Ahnung
Toni okay wenn du das sagst also
herzlich willkommen hier ist Tatort
Deutschland mein Name ist Mirko Kasimir
und bei mir ist Toni Heyer ja und was
ihr eben gehört habt und vermutlich
genauso wenig verstanden habt wie du
Mirko das ist Teil einer wirklich
mysteriösen Geschichte ah ja ja da bin
ich aber froh dass du wieder normal mit
mir redest das wäre sonst heute ganz
schön zäh geworden ja Glück für dich und
auch Glück für Euch liebe Hörerinnen und
höre mehr von diesem merkwürdigen
Buchstabensalat gibt es nicht also nicht
nur heute nicht sondern überhaupt das
ist schon der ganze Code den wir haben
ein Code der bald 80 Jahre alt und bis
heute nicht geknackt ist und von dem wir
nicht einmal ganz sicher sind ob es
wirklich ein Code oder eine geh eine
Nachricht ist oder eben einfach nur ein
Buchstabensalat aber eigentlich haben
wir ja jetzt mit dem Ende angefangen
oder stimmt Marco der Punkt geht an dich
wir gehen jetzt also erstmal ein paar
Jahrzehnte zurück und auf die andere
Seite der Erdkugel Mirko vorhang auf für
das Geheimnis des summerten Mannes
es ist kurz vor sechs die Sonne ist kaum
aufgegangen der endlose Ozean
verschmilzt mit dem tiefblauen Himmel
der landeinwärts hinter den Dünen noch
orange rot glüht der breite weiße Strand
trennt die Nacht vom anbrechenden Tag
und vergeht in der Ferne im leuchtenden
Dunst es ist der erste dezember 1948
beinahe schon Sommer am sommerten
beachen
nirgends fühlt er sich so wohl und
sicher wie auf dem Rücken seines Pferdes
mit seinem Freund Harry reitet er den
Strand entlang hinein in den neuen Tag
es gibt keine bessere Zeit für einen
Austritt die Luft ist noch kühl die
ganze Welt wie frisch geputzt der Tag
gehört ihnen die Zukunft gehört ihnen
der Strand gehört ihm einfach alles sie
sind 16 sie sind glücklich und sorglos
die ist einfach nur Teenager sein können
ein paar Schritte neben einer hölzerne
Treppe die den Wald hinauf zur
Strandpromenade mit ihren eleganten
Häusern führt setzt ein betrunkener
gegen einen Felsblock gelehnt die
ausgestreckten Beine sind lässig
übereinander gelegt eine Hand liegt im
Sand die andere hält er vor der Brust
der Mann trägt einen braunen Anzug aus
dem Revier schaut ein weißes Hemd und
eine ordentlich gebundene Krawatte mit
klassischem Streifenmuster die beiden
jungen Reiter nicken und lachen sich an
mal wieder einer der ist vom Tresen
nicht nach Hause geschafft hat und sein
Rausch jetzt am Strand ausschläft
Nil und sein Kumpel reiten weiter doch
ein paar Kilometer in Richtung
gegen 6:30 Uhr sind sie auf dem Rückweg
und bemerken ihn erneut er hat sich kein
bisschen bewegt
Nils zügeln die Pferde unsicher was
jetzt zu tun ist sollen sie ihn wecken
vielleicht wird er dann wütend und
außerdem was geht sie dieser Mann an
schließlich steigt Tori aus dem Sattel
und noch bevor sie den Fremden erreichen
wird ihnen klar dass er nicht schläft
[Musik]
der Mann am Summanden Beach ist tot Nil
und sein Kumpel Harry sind nicht die
ersten denen der Mann am Strand auffällt
gegen 7 am Arm zuvor macht das Ehepaar
Laien ein Strandspaziergang ein Mann in
einem braunen Anzug sitzt gegen den
seeballgelehnt er hebt den rechten Arm
schwach an dann lässt er ihn wieder auf
seine Brust fallen
offensichtlich ein betrunkener der
versucht sich eine Zigarette in den Mund
zu stecken das Paar geht weiter um halb
acht kommt ein anderes Paar an derselben
Stelle vorbei und bemerkt den Mann er
rührt sich nicht obwohl Moskitos sein
Gesicht umschwimmen das Paar macht einen
Witz der muss tot sein na wenn die
Wüsten aber zu diesem Zeitpunkt war er
übrigens noch nicht tot und vielleicht
wäre er auch nicht gestorben wenn der
Mann statt einen Witz zu machen zu ihm
hingegangen wäre oder die Polizei
gerufen hätte ja es gab wohl sogar noch
mehr Leute die in der sitzen sahen ohne
sich um ihn zu kümmern ich meine auch
Nil und Hori sind ja einmal an ihm
vorbei geritten aber seien wir mal
ehrlich wenn wir einen betrunkenen oder
jemanden den wir für betrunken halten
auf der Parkbank liegen sehen dann gehen
wir auch nicht unbedingt hin und fragen
ob alles in Ordnung ist
auch wenn man das besser tun sollte ja
wahrscheinlich hat man da mehr Angst
davor jemanden zu nerven oder irgendwie
übergriffig zu sein aber ich meine wenn
da schon Insekten um ihn rumschwirren
also dann würde ich ja wohl doch lieber
nachgucken ja das stimmt natürlich aber
das Pärchen ist einfach weitergegangen
wahrscheinlich war der Mann am Strand
von einem starken pahlfeld umgeben bitte
was einem talfeld sprichst du jetzt in
Rätsel nee nee hast du mal per Anhalter
durch die Galaxis gelesen um ehrlich zu
sein nein naja darin kommt jedenfalls
das pahlfeld vor damit kann man Dinge
oder Menschen einfach unsichtbar machen
aquatische
Lobotomie oder
probiotisches
antigravitationslieder naja fast Paul
steht für Problem anderer Leute
in per Anhalter durch die Galaxis wird
es so erklärt ein paar ist etwas das wir
nicht sehen können oder nicht sehen
wollen oder dass unser Gehirn uns nicht
sehen lässt weil wir denken dass es ein
Problem von jemand anderem ist das
Gehirn blendet es einfach aus es ist wie
ein blinder Fleck
und das wurde ausgenutzt um ein Gerät zu
bauen mit dem man etwas unsichtbar
machen kann indem man es mit einem
Problem anderer leutefeld umgibt okay
verstehe aber
wie sind wir jetzt vom Strand in
summerten in die Tiefen des Weltalls
gekommen okay das war jetzt so mein
Fehler sorry zurück zum Strand zum toten
Mann am Strand richtig die beiden Jungs
und ein weiterer Passant Jack Lions
Stellen ziemlich schnell fest dass der
Mann nicht mehr lebt offiziell für tot
erklärt wird er von einem hinzugerufenen
Arzt und damit beginnt die Suche nach
der Identität des Mannes und der
Todesursache man geht davon aus dass er
im Schlaf gestorben ist an seinem
rechten Kragen liegt eine nicht
gerauchte Zigarette in seinen Taschen
findet man ein unbenutztes Zugticket von
Adelaide nach Henley Beach ein Busticket
von Adelaide nach sammelten Beach einen
Aluminium kam ein halbes Päckchen juicy
fruit Kaugummis eine Packung
Streichhölzer und eine
Zigarettenschachtel aber keine
Brieftasche keine Dokumente nichts was
einen Hinweis auf seine Identität gibt
ja aber das interessanteste das ist
eigentlich die Zigarettenschachtel da
drin sind sieben Zigaretten aber es sind
Zigaretten einer anderen Marke naja
jugendlich machen das ja auch manchmal
sie kaufen halt die billigsten
Zigaretten und stecken Sie dann in die
Packung einer etwas teureren Marke naja
zumindest haben sie das früher manchmal
so gemacht ja so ein bisschen wie den
Einkauf aus dem Discounter in die Tüte
einer nobel mal umzupacken aber das
Merkwürdige ist die Zigaretten stammen
von einer teureren Marke er hat also die
Luxus Zigaretten als billig Ketten getan
dafür gibt es natürlich eine Million
mögliche und völlig unmysteriöse
Erklärungen aber es ist eben eine von
zahlreichen Merkwürdigkeiten die Leiche
wird vom Pathologen John Burton cleand
untersucht er beschreibt als von
britischer Erscheinung einen Meter 80
groß mit grauen Augen und rotblondem
Haar das an den Schläfen langsam ergraut
er schätzt ihn auf ca 40 bis 45 Jahre
seine Hände weisen keine Anzeichen von
schwerer Arbeit auf die Zehen des Mannes
laufen keilförmig zusammen was darauf
hindeutet dass er häufig spitz
zulaufende Schuhe trug seine
Wadenmuskeln sind auffällig stark
ausgeprägt was den Pathologen vermuten
lässt dass der Mann häufig Stiefel oder
Schuhe mit hohen Absätzen trug oder
Ballett tanzte der Tote ist frisch
rasiert als man seine Kleidung
untersucht stellt man fest dass alle
Etiketten herausgetrennt sind die
Polizei vermutet einen Selbstmord und
ordnet eine Autopsie an
diese wird durchgeführt von Dr dreir und
der findet neben einer halbverdauten
Pastete einige Auffälligkeiten vor allem
eine extrem vergrößerte Milz er kommt zu
dem Schluss dass der unbekannte Mann
vergiftet wurde oder sich vergiftet hat
vermutlich mit Barbituraten die damals
häufig als Schlafmittel verwendet wurden
oder mit einem löslichen Hypnotikum
beweisen kann er seinen Verdacht
allerdings nicht die Polizei
fotografiert den Toten nimmt die
Fingerabdrücke schickt sie in die ganze
Welt und lässt sogar eine Totenmaske
anfertigen und die Leiche Einbalsamieren
einfach aus dem Grund um eine spätere
Identifikation oder Untersuchungen noch
zu ermöglichen es gibt einige Hinweise
Menschen wollen in meiner Hand haben
aber das stellt sich alles als falsch
heraus die Identität des Toten vom
sammelten Beach bleibt ein Rätsel und
dieses Rätsel wird Mitte Januar 1949
noch mal ein ganzes Stück naja Rätsel
weiter am 14 januar 1949 entdeckt das
Bahnhofspersonal von Adelaide einen
braunen Koffer der am 30 November 1948
nach 11 Uhr in der bahnhofsgarderobe
abgegeben wurde er trägt kein Etikett
man vermutet sofort dass er dem
Unbekannten gehörte im Koffer befindet
sich unter anderem ein rot karierter
magenmantel rote fitzpantoffeln
Unterhosen ein Schlafanzug ein
Schraubenzieher für Elektriker und ein
schablonenpinsel wie er auf
Handelsschiffen verwendet wird sorry
aber schablonenpinsel leider wird z.B
verwendet um Frachtstücke mittels einer
Schablone zu beschriften
also dieser Koffer Inhalt ist jetzt
nicht besonders hilfreich
aber an der Kleidung im Koffer sind wie
bei der Kleidung die der Tote trug alle
Etiketten entfernt auf einer Krawatte
findet man aber einen Namen t Punkt
auch ein Wäsche Sack und eine Unterhose
sind mit Kinn beschriftet die Suche nach
einem t- aber bleibt erfolglos zumindest
in der englischsprachigen Welt wird
niemand dieses Namens vermisst eine
Sackgasse eigentlich soll der Tote noch
im Januar ein weiteres Mal untersucht
werden aber es dauert noch fünf Monate
bis sich der Gerichtsmediziner Thomas
earthkin cleanland die Leiche im Juni
erneut vornimmt ja gut dass sie den
eingeweckt haben ein balsamiert ja ja
also an der Untersuchung ist auch Cedric
stanten Hicks Professor für Physiologie
und Pharmakologie an der Universität von
adelec beteiligt er stützt die
vergiftungshypothese und nennt zwei
Gifte die in Frage kommen könnten
digitales und huaweiin eigentlich
Herzmedikamente die Namen werden
übrigens erst in den 80ern
veröffentlicht da sie vorher sehr
einfach in der Apotheke beschafft werden
konnten und man wohl niemanden auf dumme
Gedanken bringen wollte allerdings
erklärt Hicks auch dass ein Nachweis
nicht möglich sei es bleibt bei
Spekulationen und jetzt wird es richtig
seltsam ich sag nur der Ring Rover nicht
nur die Leiche wird neu untersucht man
schaut sich auch seine Kleidung noch
einmal genauer an in einer kleinen
zusätzlichen Tasche die versteckt innen
in die Hose eingenäht ist entdeckt man
ein sorgfältig zusammengerolltes winzige
Stück Papier auf dem die gedruckten
Worte kann man shoot stehen
der Zettel wurde offensichtlich aus
einem Buch herausgerissen
das ist Persisch und es bedeutet so viel
wie Ende oder beendet oder auch fertig
Angestellte der öffentlichen Bibliothek
finden heraus dass der Schnipsel aus
einem Buchstaben
[Musik]
der von 1048 bis
1.131 lebte das Buch ist eine Sammlung
von Vierzeilern deren englische
Übersetzung gegen Ende des 19
Jahrhunderts extrem beliebt war ein
Hauptmotiv des rubayat ist man solle das
Leben in vollen Zügen genießen und es
nicht bereuen wenn es endet
die herausgerissenen Worte tamam shoot
stammen von der letzten Seite des Buches
die Polizei veröffentlicht Fotos des
Zettels und bittet um Mithilfe bei der
Suche nach dem Exemplar aus dem dieser
Zettel herausgerissen wurde und die
Suche hat Erfolg ein Arzt meldet sich
bei den Behörden am Tag bevor der
sammerten Mann tot am Strand gefunden
wurde habe jemand ein solches Buch in
sein unverschlossen abgestelltes Auto
geworfen die letzten Seiten des Buches
wurden herausgerissen die Seite von der
das kleine Papierstück stammt ich weiß
ich sag das jetzt schon die ganze Zeit
aber jetzt wird es richtig mysteriös und
wir kommen endlich zu meinem komischen
gesabel vom Anfang im Einband dieses
Buches sind handschriftlich die Worte
oder besser gesagt folgende
Zeichenfolgen eingetragen darin vor aber
das reicht das
man kann sich den Zettel im Internet
auch anschauen also ihr müsst dann nur
nach summertim man googeln und dann
könnt ihr euch selber den Kopf
zerbrechen was das überhaupt bedeuten
soll so wie das schon zahllose Profis
und Amateure seit 1949 tun es scheint
sich um eine verschlüsselte Nachricht zu
handeln bisher ist es allerdings
niemandem gelungen sie zu dekodieren tja
mit diesem Rätsel werden wir leben
müssen wir wissen nicht was dieser Code
bedeutet wir wissen nicht warum der Mann
die Worte tamam Schutt herausgerissen
und so sorgfältig in einer extra
eingenähten Hosentasche versteckt hat
wir wissen auch nicht wer das Buch warum
in das Auto des Arztes geworfen hat aber
ganz so ratlos müssen wir euch zum Glück
doch nicht aus dieser Folge entlassen
denn eines der großen Rätsel dieses
Falles wurde gelöst aber erstmal wird es
ich trau mich gar nicht ist zu sagen
noch ein bisschen rätselhafter ja dem
Gedichtband findet sich auch eine
handgeschriebene Telefonnummer am
anderen Ende nimmt eine Frau ab Jessica
Ellen Thompson genannt Joe Joeys
Krankenschwester und wohnt nur 400 Meter
vom Fundort der Leiche entfernt das
klingt fast so einfach aber nichts ist
einfach an diesem Fall als Polizisten
besagte Joe befragen sagt sie dass sie
den toten Mann nicht kenne und auch
keinen Schimmer habe wie und warum Ihre
Telefonnummer in sein Buch gekommen ist
die Fotos oder die Totenmaske kann bzw
will sie nicht erkennen aber an dieser
Aussage gibt es von Anfang an Zweifel
Polizisten beschreiben ihre Reaktion
beim Anblick der Totenmaske als
verblüfft und so als würde sie gleich in
Ohnmacht fallen
Pornos und der Techniker der den Abguss
angefertigt hat erzählt später dass sie
nach dem Anblick der Büste sofort
weggeschaut habe und sie nicht wieder
habe ansehen wollen
zudem reagiert sie in den Befragungen
ausweichend verweigert die Aussage
irgendwann komplett und fordert die
Polizei auf ihren Namen nicht dauerhaft
zu speichern oder gar weiterzugeben
immerhin erzählt sie dass sie ein
Exemplar des Robert besessen habe sie
habe es allerdings schon 1945 eine Mann
namens Alf boxxel geschenkt nach
Kriegsende sei sie dann nach Melbourne
gezogen habe ihren zukünftigen Ehemann
kennengelernt und den Kontakt zu boxen
komplett abgebrochen
ist Boxer der Mann vom Strand der
Verdacht liegt erstmal nahe allerdings
findet die Polizei ihn quicklebendig in
Sydney und nicht nur Boxer geht es gut
auch seine Ausgabe des Robert die letzte
Seite ist intakt die Worte tamam Schutt
stehen wo sie hingehören damit wird es
für fast 60 Jahre still um den toten
Mann am Strand naja also so still wie es
halt um ein mysteriösen Toten werden
kann also eigentlich ja gar nicht still
denn je weniger man weiß desto mehr wird
spekuliert
dauernd ploppen neue Theorien und
vermeintliche Erkenntnisse auf unter
anderem soll der sammelten Mann ein
untergetauchter nazi-kriegsverbrecher
oder einen sowjetischer Agent gewesen
sein der wohl eine uranine und eine
Forschungseinrichtung ausspionieren
wollte vor allem die vermutete
Liebesbeziehung zwischen der
Krankenschwester Jessica Thompson und
elf Box so bietet Stoff für Geschichten
über Liebe Eifersucht und Mord es
erscheinen Bücher und enthüllungsstories
aber sie enthüllen nichts wirklich
und dann 2007 59 Jahre nachdem zwei
Jugendliche jokies eine Leiche am Strand
von Summanden gefunden haben nehmt die
Geschichte wieder richtig Fahrt auf in
diesem Jahr stirbt Jessica Thompson ihre
Tochter Kate Thompson erzählt aber in
der Sendung Sixty minutes dass ihre
Mutter die Polizei belogen habe ihre
Mutter habe die Identität des Toten sehr
wohlgekannt behauptet sie und mehr noch
auch den Behörden sei das bekannt
gewesen aber geheim gehalten worden Kate
vermutet dass sowohl ihre Mutter als
auch der sammerten Mann Spione gewesen
sein könnten ihre Mutter habe sich für
den Kommunismus interessiert und
Russisch gesprochen und ihr nie verraten
woher sie die Sprache kenne und dann ist
da noch Robin der Bruder von Kate also
der Sohn von Jessica der
Krankenschwester
der ist 2007 bereits verstorben doch
seine Witwe und deren beiden Kinder
treten ebenfalls bei sexy minutes auf
sie behaupten der Summit Mann sei der
Vater von Robin zeitlich könnte das
passen als der hammerten Mann stirbt ist
Robin 16 Monate alt die Krankenschwester
und der Unbekannte müssten sich also
mehr als zwei Jahre zuvor kennengelernt
haben
die Witwe und die beiden Kinder von
Robin Thompson verlangen eine
Exhumierung der Summanden Leiche um
seine DNA mit der DNA ihres Mannes bzw
Vaters zu vergleichen Kate weist dieses
Ansinnen zurück das sei eine
Respektlosigkeit gegenüber ihrem Bruder
zu nimmt den a-test kommt es dann doch
noch Mirko was denkst du wie lange hat
das gedauert ja vielleicht
drei Monate vier Monate
[Musik]
also ganze 14 Jahre hat das noch
gedauert bis es tatsächlich zu einem
DNA-Test gekommen ist und in der
Zwischenzeit hat sich dann ein Team der
Universität Adelaide daran versucht
unter der Leitung des Professors Derek
Abbott den Fall endlich und endgültig zu
lösen aber es gelingt ihnen nicht den
Code zu knacken sie können mit Hilfe
statistischer Methoden zumindest zeigen
dass es sich höchstwahrscheinlich
tatsächlich um einen Code handelt einen
Code der auf den Vierzeilern des Robert
basiert na toll jetzt wissen wir also
dass das Mysterium wirklich ein
Mysterium ist viel weiter bringt uns das
aber nicht
aber sie machen noch etwas Interessantes
sie schauen sich die Fotos von der
Autopsie des sammerten Mannes noch
einmal genau an und stoßen auf zwei
Auffälligkeiten das sind einmal die
Ohren des Mannes seine obere ohrmulde
ist größer als die untere ohrmulde und
das findet man nur ganz selten nur bei
ca 1 bis 2% der europäischen Bevölkerung
ist das so Mirko zeig mal deine Öhrchen
ne sieht alles gut aus
okay spaß beiseite auch an den
Schneidezähnen findet sich eine
Besonderheit die nur bei 2% aller
Menschen auftritt anhand eines Fotos des
Verstorbenen Robin Thompson also das
mutmaßlichen Sohn ist das können Sie
zeigen dass er dieselben Merkmale
aufweist die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass es
sich dabei um einen Zufall handelt geben
die Forscher mit 1 zu 10 Millionen bis
eins zu 20 Millionen an also das kann
man wohl als positiven Vaterschaftstest
durchgehen lassen mit höchster
Wahrscheinlichkeit jetzt ist man sich
ziemlich sicher Jessica und der
sammerten Mann hatten eine Beziehung und
Robin ist wahr ihr gemeinsamer Sohn aber
die Identität des Toten ist immer noch
ein Rätsel bis im Jahr 2021 die Leiche
des sammelten Mannes exhumiert und eine
DNA Probe genommen wird na endlich
endlich gibt es einen echten Fortschritt
zu vermelden und vielleicht die Lösung
für wenigstens einen Teil des Rätsels
Mirko wer war der summitenmann der
mysteriöse Tote war tadar Karl Charles
Web ein Elektro-Ingenieur und
Instrumentenbauer geboren am 16 november
1905 in einem Vorort von Melbourne davon
ist zumindest Professor Erbert überzeugt
zusammen mit der Ahnenforscherin Collien
Fitz Patrick findet er zwei entfernte
Cousins von Charles Web und kann
genetische Übereinstimmungen feststellen
die für eine Identifizierung ausreichend
scheinen es tauchen auch Fotos von Web
auf in denen man mit ein bisschen gutem
Willen den sammelten Mann erkennen kann
okay aber der muss doch dann 1948 49 als
vermisst gemeldet worden sein oder und
dann wäre man doch schon damals auf ihn
gekommen ja er wurde nie als vermisst
gemeldet viele seiner nahen Verwandten
sein Vater sein Bruder sein Schwager
starben im zweiten Weltkrieg sein
Schwager er war also verheiratet ja
allerdings verließ er seine Frau 1947
sie geht nie davon aus dass sie etwas
zugestoßen sein könnte noch 1951 drei
Jahre nach seinem Tod versuchte sie sich
von ihm scheiden zu lassen konnte aber
keine aktuelle Adresse angeben und übrig
bleibt so als wahrscheinlichste
Hypothese doch wieder die erste ein
Selbstmord mit Gift vielleicht kam er
mit all dem nicht klar mit dem Tod der
Verwandten und im Niedergang seiner Ehe
und wer weiß welche Rolle die
mutmaßliche Beziehung zu Joe der
Krankenschwester aus sammerten gespielt
haben mag
ganz ehrlich ich drehe durch jetzt haben
wir einen Namen aber von einem gelösten
Fall kann man lange nicht sprechen und
das obwohl wir die Antwort auf alle
Fragen vielleicht direkt vor Augen haben
auf einem kleinen Zettel mit ein paar
Hand geschriebenen Zeilen
darlingt
liak eten Samstag
alles klar oder nee nicht wirklich also
wenn ihr Lust habt könnt ihr euch gerne
am Rätselraten um den Code beteiligen
ihr findet ihn wirklich überall im Netz
und wenn ihr einen heißen Tipp habt dann
schickt ihr uns den natürlich per Mail
oder per Instagram die Links dazu findet
Ihr bei uns in den Show Notes danke fürs
zuhören und mit Wundern und mit Rätseln
wir hoffen dass ihr das nächste Mal auch
wieder mit dabei seid bis bald eure Toni
und euer Mirko
wir haben die Geschichte vom sammelten
Mann unter anderem anhand von Beiträgen
der BBC von
abc.net.eu und daily mail.com
und Postproduktion Wake words Studios
München Redaktion Stefan